so
hello good morning it's a little early
for those of us who came from the west
coast or for other time zones so uh
thank you for all being here
this is js conf if you're not sure if
you're not in
not supposed to be in jsconf please
leave now there's the door you still
have time to get out before we unleash
the drones
too late so i am dead program
in the real world my name is ron evans
but that's not very important right now
i'm the ringleader of hybrid group so
this other guy here is a.d
zankich also known as adrian zankich in
the real world
but most interestingly he's the serious
programming guy at hybrid group
so that means he does all the work and i
take all the credit which is nice
that's a joke or is it we'll discuss
that later exactly so we're with the
hybrid group we're a software
development company based in los angeles
california home of the flying space
robots
that is not a joke if you're a fan of
either the jet propulsion laboratory or
spacex you know i'm not actually making
this
up we're also the creators of kids ruby
which is an award-winning free and open
source tool to teach kids programming
but that's not very important we're here
to talk about javascript
robotics
this is maria i thought it was elektra
but i was confusing my mythologies
maria she's the leader of a robot
proletarian revolution but that's a
whole separate talk
let's talk about that the future is
already here
but it's not very evenly distributed at
least that's what the author and
futurist
william gibson said it's really true
isn't it
when was the last time you went to an
apple store you can buy drones there
you can even buy robots at best buy
there is a lot of amazing hardware
happening
but the software has not really kept up
with the hardware
even though you can buy all these cool
and interesting devices
there's no easy way to hook them all up
to do something useful
that's why we created cylon js
cylon.js is a javascript framework
for robotics physical computing and the
internet of things
or as i like to call it the real world
web except that doesn't flow off the
tongue
so it supports multiple hardware devices
different hardware devices
and multiple different hardware devices
at the same time
so cool this is all thanks to the
amazing concurrency that we can have
via node.js and the v8 engine so
cylon js makes programming devices
as easy as web development well you're
going web development easy yes it is
really easy
compared to the sad old days of the 90s
when we all used
gopher
thank you thank you for the history
buffs
so uh programming devices has just been
really too hard and so
silent.js is a framework designed to
make that as easy as web applications
are today
so it has a built-in api because of
course without an api you can't program
your internets over the intertubes and
that's no good you need robotic
internet control devices right it has
test driven robotics built in
we think this is really important i know
that some people claim tdd is dead
i think they're a little confused if
toyota for example yes i own
uh prius if tayo they had only used test
driven robotics as part of their brake
system
just imagine if ge or gm
you know gm with their ignition system i
mean there's a lot of
examples where people do hardware based
development and their idea of testing is
flip on the switch and then step back
hoping that it doesn't
bite you on the way it's kind of
dangerous so test driven robotics
and the command line interface because
cli is the new api
you don't want to be using gui tools to
program your devices or to get them
started
you want to be able to use a command
line interface to do all the normal
things that you would do
in fact we have a name for this we call
it robot ops it's devops for robotics
and we have a whole separate website for
this at robotops.com
our cli is actually a separate set of
tools from our robotics framework it's
called gort
you can check that out at gort.io so
gort.io for the cli tools
robotops.com for devops for robotics
but let's get to the actual demo you
guys ready to see some real robotic
devices
yeah oh hell yeah so we're going to
start with the canonical
microcontroller the arduino so the
arduino is a very very simple
microcontroller you can buy them
everywhere radio shack even sells them
yes the shack is back
if you need parts go there so here's a
very simple
example of a cylon program so the first
thing we do is we say
var cylon requires cylon which as
everybody here
probably uses node is how you bring in
the main cylon module
then we declare our robot cylon has a
declarative
syntax as opposed to an imperative one
so you define the things that you're
going to use
and then they just work so we say our
cylon robot
has a connection to an arduino
using the fermata adapter on port dev
tty acm 0 which if you're using linux as
your default serial port
so we have a single connection then we
have a single device
which is this led which is using the led
driver
on pin 13 and then the work that we're
going to do
the work that we're going to do is every
one second
we're going to my.led.toggle which will
cause the led to flash
on and off and then last we tell the
robot to start up
so we see here the three important
conceptual ideas behind cylon js the
first one is connections
which are using the adapter pattern
which is a software design pattern
similar to the way that object
relational mappers allow you to use
different kinds of database back-end
engines
without changing your code cylon.js
allows you to use hardware devices
different hardware devices but using the
same code by changing the adapter
and then the driver we're using the
double adapter pattern
so we have adapters for our connections
and then we have separate ones for
drivers so the code for an led is
exactly the same whether you're running
it on a beaglebone
black or a raspberry pi or an arduino
so here's our some video
and so we have here the arduino
and it's plugged into the largest led
that we could find
conveniently and uh
so when adrian runs the code here
it's going to be communicating using
serial interface and yes
it is blinking gratuitous applause
applause for two thousand five hundred
dollar lamp
so it's using the firmada protocol which
is running on the microcontroller itself
this is the same way that johnny 5
and a lot of other similar robotics
tools work
it's actually communicating from the
computer to the microcontroller via a
serial interface
so let's look at another device the
tessel who here has heard of the tessel
all right so tessel is a javascript
powered microcontroller you actually run
javascript that's been compiled into lua
on the device itself so we brought one
of those let's take a look at the code
the code looks almost exactly the same
as the arduino
okay we once again we declare cylon we
say our cylon robot
this time the connection is to a tesl
using the tessel adapter
but otherwise it's exactly the same
we're still using the led device
the work that we're doing is exactly the
same every one second we're going to
my.led.toggle
so we'll so not everyone has actually
had a chance to look at one of these
little guys
yeah they're i believe shipping on
monday
that's what the email said so uh
so this is the uh tesla it's plugged
into exactly the same breadboard
with the same led you know because we're
trying to save money
well also you know mercury lead there's
a lot of nasty chemicals in your
electronics don't just throw them into
trash
properly recycle them all right moving
on so
we're going to run the exact same code
and this time however
we're going to compile the cylon code
and it's going to execute right on the
tesla itself
so example one we were on the computer
talking to a microcontroller
example two with the tassel we're going
to do the exact same thing
and yes tesla blink
let's see now we're down to a much more
reasonably cost
flashing lamp yeah just so just so you
know
the previous example with the arduino my
computer was communicating to the
arduino through the serial interface
this one the code is actually running on
the board itself so with silent.js you
can actually write
your firmware that runs on this
microcontroller itself so you don't need
a computer at all for this
so the only reason why i'm plugged into
this is for power
so if i had a battery pack or something
this could be completely isolated
somewhere with the firmware running
written in silent js somewhere doing
something controlling some led somewhere
exactly somewhere in the world an led is
blinking
all right so now let's move on to the
beaglebone black
so the beaglebone black is a single
board system-on-chip linux microcomputer
it's very similar to a raspberry pi but
better
if better is defined as more processor
more memory and more capabilities
so the beaglebone black we have cylon js
running on there
let's look at the code should look
exactly like the code you've already
seen right in this case
once again require cylon we're making a
connection this time using the
beaglebone adapter
and once again the same our friend the
led driver but we named the pin a little
differently
in cylon js we have mappings so that
whatever is labeled on the board
is what you use in your code so no more
looking through data sheets trying to
figure out the mysteries of
naming and it turns out this one is 43
but that one's actually p2
underscore 12 or in this case p9
underscore 12.
so we make it a lot easier for you to
just look at how it's labeled
write the code the same way plug it in
and it should just work let's just take
a quick look
here is again the tesla code here is the
arduino code so arduino code
tussle code beaglebone block code
same basic code just with little tiny
tweaks you see a pattern studying the
form
all right so let's take a little look at
the beetle bone
it looks very much like all these boards
tend to look it's a
surface mount components with some
heathers the beaglebone black has i
believe 68
digital i o lines that can be used for
general purpose i o
for analog for i square c which a lot of
devices like
lcds and accelerometers and other things
use
and so adrian is going to well tell us
what you're going to do
allow me to explain so
so we have node.js running on this
beaglebone black
so this computer this is actually a
full-fledged arm-based linux computer
so these two previous examples this
arduino is a microcontroller that we are
communicating with over a serial
interface
remotely controlling the pins this tesl
is a microcontroller that runs
javascript directly on the board so this
has no operating system
just running pure code this is a full
linux computer
which we're writing a cylon program that
runs on the computer so
uh you know it's three different use
cases for
how you'd control pins and that sort of
thing so
let's uh run this program really quick
he's ssh'd in and so he's actually
executing the code
on the beaglebone black itself or he
would be if it hit run
this is how you know it's real
and it blinks yes
all right hello
i'm going to do a karaoke song no just
kidding all right
so this is the perfect time for the
choose your own hardware adventure
yes choose your own hardware adventure
because we came provisioned with all
sorts of awesome gear from our wonderful
friends in case you're wondering how we
got so much of it
so this is your opportunity to get some
of this
so to win a sphero 2.0 to win the sphere
2.0
just go on the twitterverse and tweet
ghost sphero
and cylon js okay so ghostfair on
silent.js if you want to win a sphero
2.0
if you want to win a pebble smartwatch
tweet pebble
and cylon js and if you want to win a
beaglebone black
tweet beagleboard org kinda long
beagleboard oregon's highline.js so
those twitter names again
to win the sphero tweet ghost pharaoh
and cylon js
to win the pebble tweet pebble and cylon
js or to win a beaglebone black
tweet beagleboard org and cylon.js
all right on with the show sphero plus
leap motion
all right so a bunch of people have seen
the sphero
it's a very cool we call it the minimum
viable robot
it is a a toy it looks like a toy it is
in fact
a toy but it does have a few interesting
characteristics
one of them has input it has a built-in
accelerometer so we can detect
collisions
the other is that it has two different
forms of output
one is that it can roll around it has a
built-in
accelerometer as i mentioned so it can
auto stabilize the same way as a segway
or a mip or some other kinds of robotic
devices
and it can change the color of its
built-in rgb led
so let's take a look the code here is a
little bit more complicated we could see
now an example of using two different
devices at the same time
so we have two connections we have the
leap motion connection
and then the sphero connection so the
leap motion
uh the leap motion is a gestural
controller
that plugs directly into your computer
and then allows you through its built-in
camera
and infrared projector to figure out
where your hands are positioned and use
those as a way without any wires at all
to control some kind of device
so it puts out the data via websockets
and so you can see here's the poor
that's running on
then the sphero the sphero work it's a
bluetooth device but we're using
a bluetooth serial connection so again
our old friend
in this case it's rfcom0 which is the
typical
port used by linux again if you're doing
robotics and you're not using linux
you're probably doing it wrong
but that's a whole nother rant so then
we have two devices the leap motion and
the sphero
then the work that we're going to do
we're going to turn on the tail light to
the sphero so we can tell which way it
is pointing
or pointing away from then here is our
event
syntax that looks exactly like the kind
of event syntax that you've seen as a
node developer because in fact it is
so on my.leapmotion.on hand
we grab that data from the hand and we
scale it using some of our built-in
scaling functions since you have to do a
lot of scaling
when you're moving from for example the
leap motion to a servo or something of
that sort so we scale
the hand x and y coordinates
to something that the sphero can use
then every one second
we're going to roll the sphero or we're
going to sorry we're going to set the
color to a random color
then every 0.01 seconds we're going to
look at that data from the leap motion
and decide which direction to roll
around in the reason we have to do this
is we need some way to manage the
concurrency
the leap motion puts out data a lot
faster because you can wave your hands
very quickly and they can detect that
a lot more quickly than the physical
device can respond in this case the
sphero
and then lastly cylon.start
so let's go back to my camera
so that was this way we can kind of see
both his hand
so he's waving his hand
okay that's better
look ma just a hand
this is really fun uh we by the way we
have a table
in the makerspace area along with the
nodebots team and the node rockets team
and a bunch of other cool people
so uh if you are wandering around and
you're bored of the hallway track
and you just don't have the attention
span you know come on in there we have
lots of parts
and you can play with this stuff
we have a leap motion that each person
could use but you can't keep them or
else we're going to get in big trouble
all right so
sphero plus robo so
uh we're gonna show something completely
different now with the sphero um
who here knows conway's game of life
all right so only a few mathematical
people
so uh a brief description so there was
this guy
named john conway not john connor that's
a fictional character
john conway john conway a man completely
obsessed with mathematic
specifically he keeps looking at these
flocks of seagulls and he knows seagulls
are not especially intelligent and yet
they fly in these amazing formations
he can't stop thinking about it like all
mathematicians and he sits down
with a piece of paper and thinks really
hard and solves a problem and that
problem becomes a whole new field of
mathematics that we call
cellular automata or more popularly
artificial life
so he makes this game known popularly as
conway's game of life and it's normally
played on graph paper
which i highly recommend you go out and
get a path of graph paper because it's
an amazing tool for creativity
all good ideas start on graph paper you
don't have to stay within the lines you
can just
know they're there and it makes you feel
nice all right so conway's game of life
these little circles
are cells and the squares are an absence
of cells
so each one of them follows the same
basic set
of three rules so the first rule is if
you are a cell and you have less than
two neighbors you die because of
loneliness
if you have exactly two other neighbors
then a new cell is born
into an empty square and if you have
three neighbors then you die from
overpopulation
so with these same basic three sets of
rules you go through each one of the
squares and depending on whether it has
a cell or not you apply these rules
so first move would look like this and
the second one would look like this
so we thought it'd be really cool to
create conway's game of life
but with robots just take anything in
the universe and add with robots and see
what it does it's kind of fun
so but we realized there were going to
be a few changes we'd have to make
first of all we don't have a really fast
3d printer that can create new spheros
on the fly in case you're wondering how
we get new ones to be born
working on that also they have no eyes
they can only detect collisions by way
of the built-in accelerometer
so because we are also mathemagicians we
use something called an inverse fourier
transform
which basically allows us to take a
slice of time and then using the number
of collisions we detect within that
slice of time we create
a number which corresponds to the
approximate number of neighbors
all right you guys got that cool moving
on so here's the code
so what we're going to do is we're going
to run five spheros
which we've named thelma louise grace
aydah and mary
that mary is supposed to be missy which
stands for missy cummings first
uh female fighter pilot in the united
states navy and an associate professor
of human machine interfaces
and i believe duke anyway um
so each one of these spheros is going to
be running the exact same code so let's
see what that code is
so our conway robot we have a connection
and a device
which we're going to fill in the port
number when we start them all up
then they're born when they're born we
set the number of contacts and age to
zero
they have life and they have movement so
when they move they move around in a
random direction
that's a little bit different there is
no randomness in the original conway
game but we're very random people
so uh we thought it'd be fun so when
they come to life
they are alive and they turn green when
they die they stop moving
and they turn red if they have enough
contacts then they can stay alive
so when one of these robots has its
birthday we call it happy birthday
if it has enough contacts and it's not
alive meaning already dead it comes back
to life
zombie mode zombie robots
it's real otherwise they die if they
don't have enough contacts
and so then the work that we do is
we connect start detecting collisions
we detect them and we keep this counters
every three seconds we move if we're
still alive
every 10 seconds we have a birthday so
life is hard
short and spherical in spheroland and
then we're going to start out for each
one of the bots that we declared
initially in that first array we're
going to go through
and we're going to say here's a new
conway robot we're going to tell it
which port and what name it has and then
we're going to start it out
and then this line here we're going to
turn on cylon js's built-in api
it has an express.js api built right in
and we also have a single page web app
built using angularjs
called robo so similar to the way your
router
has an admin page that's just built
right in we have robo built right into
all of the cylon js
code that you write that way you can
test to see well in my case my code is
not working but why
that's the interesting question we can
go in and we can use robo to figure that
out
so first of all let's
is the rather still on it says its own
we brought her on wifi something to do
with not trusting conference wifi
can't imagine
you disconnected you didn't pay your att
bill
no it says it's my mifi
oh i didn't pay my bill um
well let's now it's back on oh
well we saw the att uh cell tower here
it's uh in a truck that's parked kind of
on the back 40.
this is not a joke we could show it to
you later if you don't believe us
if you want cellular signal just kind of
point and don't move
all right he's going to connect you'll
know that they're connected because they
stop flashing
they take on the sustained color
standing by
they're thinking think think think
think
just imagine when you're in orbit and
you're waiting like uh we're waiting uh
houston
we're standing by
yeah exactly 45 minutes later when you
ping mars and you're
uh it didn't work hmm 45 minutes later
you ping mars again
that's weird at work this time
all right well four out of five
all right they're rolling around they're
looking for love in all the wrong places
they need to collide with each other
actually with anything
some people have said how do you tell
when they only collide with each other
and not the walls well
a wall is a sphero tourist pharaoh
and he's going to restart it really
quick
okay okay
standing by
the death star explodes that's a very
interesting question he asks
when does the death star explode that
brings up the question
was it contractor failure
or were they partisans who inserted a
design flaw intentionally we could
discuss this at the bar later
but i'm original trilogy for life keep
that in mind
hmm almost there
all right we're gonna go to the next
demo if you don't get it this time
i'm getting bored i mean i don't got all
day
so little to do so much time wait strike
that
reverse it
yes no not that that one didn't count
do not look at the sphero behind the
curtain
is this not running
something's not going
all right i'm ready to move on to the
next demo
well they they're not playing well with
each other actually
we have nothing to do with this game
there is no human
robot yet all right so
let's move on to the next demo uh if you
want to see the conway's game of life
with pharaohs
come find us in the hackerspace all
right let's get into some drones
because since we didn't have the spheros
working not having the drones working
will be so much more interesting
so uh we have support for the ar drone
uh thanks to the hard work of the
node copter team which we wrap around
like many of the libraries we use if you
hadn't noticed we support all the same
hardware
plus a lot more it's because we are
staying on the shoulders of giants
not on their toes so we're going to show
an ar drone
with opencv a ps3 controller
and a neurosky so what is this all about
so the ar drone it's the popular parrot
ar drone that if you've been to a node
copter you've already flown
we're going to be using opencv which is
an open source computer vision package
that is very very commonly used for
things like facial recognition or edge
detection
we're going to fly it around with a ps3
controller which we're using
um i believe we're using a library that
was partly created by andrew nesbit
and then we're going to use the neurosky
brainwave reader
we're not going to fly the drone with
the brain
that would not be a very good idea
because most people do not have enough
brain control
to even fly without a brain controller
instead
we're going to monitor the brain waves
of our pilot
and if he gets really nervous we'll know
all right so put that on here let's take
a look at some code while he's getting
ready
so once again var cylon requires cylon
that's how everything starts out and
then we dynamically include the modules
that are needed for whatever hardware
you're using
in this case we're using three
connections we have a connection to
opencv
we have a connection to the dual shock 3
joystick
and we have a connection to the ar drone
itself
then we have four devices the first one
is the matrix
not the matrix you're thinking of this
is the matrix that's used by opencv for
its optical recognition
then after that we have the window
so that we can actually see what the
drone sees we have the controller for
the dushock 3
and then we have the drone itself flight
commander so we can control it
so we have a little helper to validate
our pitch so we don't flip over
then the work that we're going to do is
we're going to grab the data
and we're going to show it on the screen
okay so every time we get a new png
file from the camera we're going to
display it inside of the window
then based on the different controllers
we're going to either take off
if you press the square if you press the
triangle will hover
if you press x will land etc
then every zero so if you ever use set
interval
uh you probably wondered at its api
because it's really confusing we didn't
like it so we wrote our own little
helper around it
every zero does something as quick as it
can but asynchronously
so every zero we're going to grab the
joystick info and then based on whether
you put it left right turning or pitch
or yaw we're going to change those
then similar fashion we're going to do
the same thing for the
rotation and then if we lose control
we're going to hover
then here's the code for the neurosky
headset we're running another little
separate cylon program
we're just grabbing the neurosky data
and then we're going to log it
so let's see if this works here
all right i gotta run my code
all right okay there's adrian's brain on
javascript
so uh we could tell if he's getting
really nervous
uh the door is right there under the
tables works the battery life of the ar
drone is maybe
7 to 12 minutes of full flight
good to know right
and this way we can kind of see
now we really are standing by
standing by
yeah everyone turn off your wi-fi just
kidding
banking working
working working
let's go see what his brain has been
doing this whole time
looks kind of erratic bro
so now you're trying to decide should i
watch the drone or watch his brain
there is a lot of interference in your
brain or the drone
if it crashes into you we're really
sorry
all right so cylon ps3 ar drone
and neurosky
no humans were injured all right we have
one last demo and then we got to get out
of here because there's a lot of other
cool people doing a lot of other cool
things
so now we're going to show you the
mother of all demos we're going to show
you a pebble watch that's
featuring r2 controlling an ar drone
with opencv
doing facial recognition then
controlling some spheros and the
digispark running on the drone itself
in other words r2
so well let's explain very briefly so
what is r2 r2
is the same idea cylon js but it's
written in ruby we call it ruby on
robots because we love many languages
so we're going to use r2 communicating
with a pebble smartwatch
here's the code same exact idea as what
you saw we don't have time to go through
the whole thing but it's the same basic
idea of what you already saw
but in ruby same design software
architectural design pattern
in this case we're going to detect when
the button pushes and then we're going
to start the whole thing off using the
api
all right so then we're going to
communicate
with our drones running cylon js in this
case we're going to be doing the facial
recognition part so that's why we need
the matrix again
so we're going to look at your face and
if it's recognized based on the generic
human face
so any human will work basically when we
detect that face
if we detect a face we're going to send
an api command
to another microcontroller that's
running on the drone itself
so we have a very very small little usb
powered microcontroller called the
digispark which is plugged into the usb
port that's on the ar drone
and we have this led plugged into the
top of it attached via
either electrical or duct tape depending
on what was available
so um when it detects that it's going to
send a command that we're going to flash
the led
on the top of the drone so when it's
looking at a human and it detects it
the led will start to blink the spheros
will start to go crazy
you will be able to see a green outline
around the human face
through our universal video adapter and
so we're controlling
the we're actually running code on the
ar drone itself it's actually a single
board linux computer of its own
and we're using gobot which is our go
language
framework so we're basically we have r2
is going to tell
the cylons to command gobot
if everything goes well and here's a
some go code if you haven't looked at go
this is the go code that we're running
on the ar drone itself
that's um basically it's that same blink
that you saw before
but now implemented in go and
communicating with the digispark
all right so now
he's waking them up everything all at
once
in one massive demo what could go wrong
nothing could go wrong especially if
you're sitting in the back you're pretty
safe
normally we choose a volunteer
slash test object slash target
but now that we can start it all off
through the pebble that means he gets to
be both the serious programmer and
human subject
a human subject it sounds really nice
you've got humanity
you're you are the point of the whole
thing how can you complain
it's all about you man
how many devices can we use all at once
we could probably add a few more but we
don't have enough time
in fact we're losing devices rapidly
device attrition started out with like
4d and you end up with three
there could only be one
think think think think
all right let's do this
do you need me to increase the screen
size when it runs
okay
all right so you get in front of the
drone you get between me and the drone
all right
there it goes
where's the video there it is
oh oh it spotted somebody else behind
you quick throw yourself between him and
it
so you see the light on top is flashing
every time that you see the green square
because when it recognizes a face
friendly or otherwise
there's too many humans in this room
all right the mother of all robotics
demos
was that fun did you guys have fun did
you enjoy that
i certainly did thank you so join the
robot
evolution not revolution that those
usually don't work but the evolution
seems to work fairly well given our
current status
so join us cylon js.com or cylon js on
twitter
r2.io or r2io on twitter if you prefer
ruby
gobot.io or gobotio if you would like to
explore the exciting world of
concurrency in the go programming
language
thank you very much
you